[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست ال ازاي نعمل فيلم سياسي
كوميديان واحد بيدافع عن السجاير من غير
ما نشجع الناس انهم يشربوا سجاير اجابه
السؤال ده في اسم الفيلم thank you الاسم
الساخر اللي هنخوض معاه الرحله وورقه
كواليس صناعه وترويج السجائر كمنتج
والمقتبس من اسم الروايه المبني عليها
الفيلم للكاتب كريستوفرى انا محمود النجار
والنهارده هنتكلم عن ما وراء فيلم
المخرج جيسون روتمان بيفتح الفيلم بمقابله
تلفزيونيه اشبه بمناظره مع البطل
المدافع عن السجائر وطفل عنده كانسر في
الرئه ومجموعه مختلفه من الناس المعارضه
للسجاير وبيظهر من اول دقيقه معارضه شديده
جدا لسه سجاير بسبب كميه المعارضين وحتى
الطريقه اللي بيتكلم بيها هناك رئيس
اكاديميه الطبخ اللي بتصير شمئزاز الجمهور
كله البطل عموما عارف انه شخص مكروه بس
القصه قصته وهو الراوي لها فبيقول بمنتهى
الوضوح ان نسبه قليله من الناس عارفين
انها مكروهه وانه اكيد واحد منهم وبيقارن
نفسه بناس اباده البشريه زي جنكيز خان
مثلا كمان البطل عارف انه سلاحه الوحيد هو
الكلام ده الشيء الوحيد اللي هو بارع فيه
والسبب في شغله اصلا فطول الوقت بيغلب على
الفيلم وصوته كراوي للقصه في حاجات
هتلاحظها من اول الفيلم لحد اخر الفيلم زي
مثلا ما فيش ولا مشهد من ابطال الفيلم
بيدخنوا فيه والمشاهد التدخين كانت من
نصيب اللي بتشتغل جوه الفيلم والممثلين
مجرد بيتفرجوا عليها طول الفيلم بياكد على
ان التدخين شيء ضار وده بيظهر في شمئزاز
الناس لما نيك المدافع عن السجائر بيتكلم
او لما زوج طليقه البطل اللي هو دكتور
كاضافه كوميديه بيقول انه بلاش تدخن
حوالين ابنك لان التدخين ضار او في حملات
اللي موجوده دايما علشان تقول للناس قد
ايه التدخين سيء وبتعمل شعارات وبتاكد ان
التدخين سم وبتطالب انها تتطبع على
السجاير ده غير ان الفيلم كوميديا بيركز
على دور الميديا في الترويج الشرس للسجاير
الفيلم عموما مش بيجبرك طول الوقت على
تبني قناعه معينه احنا كده كده عارفين ان
السجاير شيء مضر وبشع بس في الغالب بيوريك
كواليس الصناعات ازاي ممكن تروج لفكره
سيئه وازاي على الجانب الاخر ممكن ترفضها
وتقنع الناس برفضها ودائما اللعب على
مشاعره الجمهور هو بطل القصه فمثلا لما
نرجع للمقابله التلفزيونيه اللي حصلت في
اول فيلم هنلاقي ان البطل والم مثل لجماعه
الدفاع عن السجائر بينال اعجاب رؤسائه وهو
الشخص اللي انتصر في المقابله دي بينما
رانجودي الشخص المناهض للسجاير واللي تبع
منظمات البيئه بيتم تبويخه على دوره في
المقابله وانه مقدرش يدير المناظره لصالحه
ورئيسه بيقول له بشكل مباشر انه فشل في
استعطاف الجمهور لانه كان لازم يظهر الطفل
المصاب بالسرطان بشكل اكثر اثاره للتعاطف
ده اول درس بيعلمه الاب نيك نيلر لابنه
وهو بيحاول يكتب واجب المدرسه واول
استخدام من ابنه جوي للدرس ده بيبقى على
امه اللي بيقنعها تسيبه يسافر مع ابوه
ودعمه من توضيح لمدى تاثير نيك على اي شخص
حواليه وعلى قدرته العاليه للتلاعب بالناس
اللي قدرت تخليه الممثل لشيء زي الدفاع عن
السجاير مثلا الفيلم عموما بيدور جوه اطار
عن فلسفات الاقناع والتلاعب وبيقدم حاجه
شبه حوار الاخلاق فنكنير مطلوب منه ان هو
يقدم رشوه للوجه الاعلاني المتقاعد لشركه
مارلبورو اللي اصيب بكنسل في الرئه وحاول
يفضح ويقدم ويقف قدام الشركه دي نيك هنا
شايف ان الشخص ده كاكاو بوي او كراعي بقر
اكيد مش هيقبل الرشوه ده جزء من اخلاقه بص
رئيسه اقنعه انه عادي دي مش رشوه ولا حاجه
دي هديه بس علشان يقلل ضغطه علينا شويه
فنك وهو بيقدم الفلوس للشخص عمل مسرحي
شويه وبدا حواره معايا بانها مش رشوه ولا
حاجه وانك ممكن تستخدم الفلوس دي ضدنا لو
رفضتها فخد الفلوس اطلب مقابله تلفزيونيه
وافضحنا وقدم الفلوس دي للجمعيات المناهضه
لنا والريفيرس بتلعب لعبتها وبعد ما كان
الراجل رافض وشاف ان هناك شخص الطف من انه
يشتغل مع الناس دي قبل الفلوس فعلا وهيوقف
حملته ضدهم في الجنب كده في عرض دائم
للاخلاء والمعايير الاخلاقيه للبشر من
خلال جوينينج اللي بيسال اسئله بدي هي طول
الوقت بيعرض من خلالها قناعات وشكل اخلاق
نيك عموما معترف طول الوقت انه مش صاحب
احسن بوصله اخلاقيه وان كل اللي بيعمله
وانه بيدي حريه الاختيار للعالم بس علشان
ما ينفعش يبقى العالم عموما بيقرر لك حتى
لو كان قرار العالم صح النيك بيتلقى على
الهواء مباشره تهديد بالخطف وبيتخطف فعلا
والاشخاص اللي بيخطفوه بيقرروا يغطوا جسمه
بلزقات نيكوتين بكثافه كافيه انها تقتله
كاوفر دوز نيكوتين بس
كتغيير غريب في الاحداث الدكتور بيقول له
ان اللي انقذه من الموت انه اصلا شخص مدخن
وهنا القضيه بتتقلب كليا علشان نجمع
ورقتين ضغط مهمين جدا على الراي العام
اولا انه ضحيه قدام العالم وثانيا انه
اللي انقذه فعلا انه شخص مدخن بس كتفادي
للازمه دي بتيجي التانيه لماهر الصحفيه
اللي هناك كان بيعتبرها صديقته وبيحكي لها
اغلب كواليس شغله بتنشر مقاله بكل اسرار
والعالم بيعرف كل كواليس الترويج للسجائر
واستخدام الميديا في الترويج لهم ده غير
انها بتفضح حتى شكل تربيه نكل ابنه وازاي
انه تقريبا بيربيه علشان يبقى
الخليفه وهنا هنتكلم عن الحوار اللي دار
ورا الفيلم ده الفيلم ماخوذ اصلا عن روايه
ثانكيو للكاتب بعد اصدارها اشتروا حقوق
ملكيتها الفنان علشان كان شايف نفسه كممثل
مناسب جدا بس للاسف ما قدرش يطلع مناسب
للعمل واللي قدر يطلع منها المناسب كان
جيسون ريتمان مخرج الفيلم
جدا ووافق عليه بس وقف مشكله انتاجيه وده
لان الاستوديوهات وشركات الانتاج كان
عندها تعديلات مختلفه شويه على انهم مثلا
كانوا عايزينه يخلي نهايه النهايه سعيده
وفيها تغيير حقيقي لشخصيته بس يا ريت ما
كانش موافق وكانهايه للفيلم راتمان اختار
اختيارات احسن للبطل بس مش اختيارات فيها
تغير جذري لشخصيته فبعد ما هيبعد عن كونه
مدافع عن السجاير هيشتغل كمستشار في تعليم
الناس ازاي يجادلوا فبيفضل جوهر البطل في
مهاره المفضله كشخص بيعرف يتكلم كمان كان
عنده مشكله ان الروايه شرسه جدا في
مهاجمتها لشركات السجاير ووقت اصدارها
عملت مشاكل وتضارب كتير في الوسط السياسي
لان كاتبها اصلا ناقه
لان كاتبها اصلا ناقص سياسي بس يا ريتمان
كان شايف فيها اكتر من مجرد روايه معارضه
وده ساعد جدا في نجاح الفيلم وبقداره
مخرجه كويسه جدا على فيلم الطويل الاول
قدر يقدم عمل كوميدي بيحافظ على الفكره
الاصليه ومستوى قبوله اكبر عند الجمهور
اللي ساعه في ده انه كان شايف نفسه في
كتابه في الروايه اللي مبني عليها الفيلم
فاختار مكانه الصح وقدم تجربه ناجحه على
مختلف المستويات الفيلم اخيرا خرج النور
لما رتمان قدر يقابل ديفيد مدير شركه
بايبال واللي مو الاغلب ميزانيه الفيلم
بثمانيه مليون دولار وبمنتج لاول مره في
تاريخه ومخرج لاول مره حققه اكتر من 39
مليون دولار كارباح الفيلم مترشح لجوائز
مختلفه الاخراج والتمثيل وحتى الموسيقات
التصويريه بس نصيبه من الترشيحات او
الجوائز ما كانش كبير بما يكفي بس بشكل
عام قدر ينال اعجاب الجمهور والنقاد
واتوصف بانه عمل خفيف على الرغم من
كوميدية السوداء دلوقتي محتاج اعرف منك هل
ممكن تتفق مع نيك نيلور في قناعاته او
ارائه واصراره على انه مجرد بيطالب بحريه
اختيار الناس ولا انت شايف ان هو مجرد شخص
متلاعب بيخدم مصالحه الشخصيه واستناني
الحلقه اللي جايه في حلقه جديده من بودكا
الافلام علشان نحكي عن ما وراء فيلم جديد
بمنظور مختلف ومنظور ما وراء الافلام
[موسيقى]